hello everyone it looks like we are live
and we're getting better at starting on
time thanks for joining us at our lot
daily live stream at our new time that
we started yesterday now today at 12
Pacific through Eastern and many people
are from joining from all over the world
we're calling this a bit of a homeroom
because obviously in this time of school
closures and social distancing people
can use things like Khan Academy at
their own time and pace but I think we
all crave a little bit of social
connection and a way to to realize that
what we're going through the whole world
is going through and as as troubling is
the scenario we are in as a civilization
there's the silver lining is we I think
in some strange way feel more connected
and one real you know humanity is one
group of people right now so just for
those of you all this is the first time
that you're attending one of these live
streams with this home homeroom that we
do every day it's really a catch-all for
answering questions getting
announcements out there really just like
homeroom in real classrooms and it's not
just for students it's for parents it's
for teachers it's for anyone else who
has questions of any form just to get
everyone up to speed on what the
resources that are already out there
from Khan Academy
obviously for over a decade we've been
building resources that start you as
early as pre-k our Khan Academy kids app
the it's suitable for students as young
as three all the way up through the
first grade Common Core Standards up
through six year olds and then on the
main Khan Academy app or website you can
for sure get math from kindergarten all
the way through middle school high
school and the core of college and also
sciences at the high school level some
humanities at the high school level and
we just launched what we call a beta
which is almost like a pre-release
of English and language arts for grades
2 through 8 we also have free SAT
practice which is a partnership with a
college board that's in reading math and
writing and we also have topics like
economics
and others that I mean I could I could
keep going on about so those resources
were always all there but as soon as we
realized that the school closure
situation was happening a few weeks ago
we we realized we have to step up more
we have to provide more resources so
that's when we started the livestreams
we've been running teacher and parent
webinars to help teachers and parents
understand what resources there are and
how they get started we have also
published a schedule a little over a
week ago that for students of different
age groups what could be an indicative
schedule for them how you can structure
their day leveraging resources from Khan
Academy and other resources including
you know dance videos on YouTube for
your PE or you might want to go outside
and run around or there might be some
form of reading lists this week some of
you all realize we just did it a couple
of hours ago
we are also experimenting with doing
academic webinars so a few hours ago we
ran our first one which was on algebra
and we focused on the topic of systems
of equations and we had great you know
we had a thousand students participating
and we're taking the video and we're
gonna put it on our YouTube channel and
probably promote on social media as well
so you'll at least see a recording of it
and I hope many of you have a chance to
join some of these future classes so
with that one thing I want to say you
know where we're trying to put out all
of these resources but one question that
we're getting from a lot of parents is
they're just feeling a little bit
overwhelmed right now how do they focus
on things you know are they doing a
disservice to their children if if they
don't have everything all figured out
just yet and the one thing I want to
make very clear to you is no one has it
all figured out just yet even in my own
house
you know I've figured out some what for
especially my older kids but my
five-year-old we're figuring it out but
it is getting day day by day better and
so I think the important thing to
appreciate as a parent there's a lot of
things going on right now you're working
from home a lot of people in an
unfortunate situation where even they
might not be able to work now and then
you have to there's childcare as an
issue and so keep it simple especially
in the first week or two it's not the
end of the world
if things are a little bit less
structured
if your kids if you're just having
quality time with your kids or just
whatever it takes to get through the day
but I think as as we go on try to just
make sure that the kids get a little bit
of a reading every day a little bit of
math every day we have suggestions
obviously Khan Academy as a resource for
both and there's reading lists for the
on the reading side of things you know
if your kids are old enough encourage
them to journal and then over time you
could try to layer on more things try to
do more and more of the types of
schedules we've published those
schedules are not meant to be rigid they
are meant to be evolving documents we
are evolving them and you can adapt them
to your own needs but this session we
want to make it as interactive as
possible so I encourage everyone if
you're on Facebook YouTube Twitter start
putting your questions in and we have a
team of Khan Academy folks we're gonna
be looking at them and surfacing the
questions it looks like a lot of people
are thinking about I also want to
introduce my colleague Dan to who's kind
of co-hosting this livestream today and
we're gonna actually this is fun because
we figured out the technology hopefully
over the coming live streams we'll be
able to bring different guests in and
people who can help out with this but
Dan's gonna help he's in contact with
the team that is surfacing the questions
so please please send send in your
questions I'll start with one I see
Stacy Wilber from facebook says can you
please put in an adult program so adults
can get their diplomas please Stacy
that's one of the dreams of Khan Academy
we don't issue things like diplomas but
I do we do know a lot of stories about
especially adults leveraging Khan
Academy to prepare for things like their
GED or their you know whatever graduate
requirements for high school diplomas
they might have so that's where we could
support you right now but it is a dream
to one day be able to connect to work on
Khan Academy to you know real life
economic or academic outcomes and Dan
feel free to I see another question from
Facebook shahla Karimi says Salaam I
have fifth grade first grade and
something younger daughters why when
it's a little typo they are all acting
out and they are really emotional since
they are home due to virus how can I
help them
well shallow that's a great question I
think right now there's probably about a
billion parents who are experiencing
some version of what you're experiencing
including myself so I think the first
thing to realize is don't don't beat up
on yourself and think it's just like
you're the only person who maybe you
know your kids are acting out and
especially you know if they have to stay
at home and they're not getting as much
social interaction as possible I'm not a
child psychology expert I actually hope
we can bring some in into these live
streams all I can tell you is try to
leverage things like video conferencing
if you have access to it so that they
can connect with their friends we've
been doing playdates at home obviously
with my youngest who's five years old
we've been moderating his his playdates
with some of his five year old friends
which can get a little chaotic if you
don't want to help them out a little bit
we've been ensuring that you know in
this time of social distance you can
still take walks and still have exercise
outside you just have to keep distance
from other people but we're being quite
religious about making sure that we go
outside at least twice a day if we can
even if it's raining we're getting the
umbrellas out and saying we're going for
a walk because I think it's really
valuable to get that and then I think
what we're seeing in our own household
is still a little bit interesting
sometimes but just everyone is getting a
little bit used to this new normal which
is obviously too suboptimal normal but I
think things will get better we've had a
homeschooling parent in the past say
just try to stick with it it does get
better the kids will get used to it
obviously the suboptimal situation for
everyone but the number one thing is
also take care of yourself don't get so
overwhelmed because obviously the more
as parents we get overwhelmed and we'll
snap at our children and then everyone
will get stout so the more that you can
kind of keep calm whatever does to get
you know whatever you do in your life to
get to that meditative state
give yourself some alone time so that
you'll have that emotional Reserve to to
deal with where the kids might the
supports they might need
Fazlu from YouTube Faizal Kabir 'ln if
I'm reading it correctly this is a
crucial moment of coronavirus how can a
student from Bangladesh continue his
studies online okay so it looks like
facile this is from Bangladesh thanks
for joining us I think a little late
there
so you know depending on your level
facile I think the the key is is that
you actually you could view this as a
glass-half-full scenario where a lot of
the the demands on your time especially
for younger students they might have had
a lot of social engagements and other
extracurricular activities or homework a
lot of those have been loosened and so a
that Khan Academy is a great place to
focus on those subjects that you really
want to make sure you have a strong
foundation in the high school subjects
early college subjects biology chemistry
physics economics there's other things
off-site
you know if you've graduated outside of
Khan Academy you can move on to things
like MOOCs and take more advanced
courses at a university level I think
it's a great time to take on projects
where it's one thing to learn a lot of
academic things but can you apply it can
you create you know can you know create
invent something that can solve problems
for folks right make a software
application that can do something so I
think there's a lot of opportunity but I
think that's the best way to be
constructively occupied right now and
obviously there might be opportunities
to volunteer for people in your
community who might need help if you're
a young person you are you should you
have to you should be still socially
distanced but you might be able to help
older people who might have trouble
leaving their houses and have to be even
more social distance you know with
things like getting groceries or
honestly just connecting with them you
know keep distance and say hello or send
them a text message or just make sure
they feel socially connected cool
questions that are related
um questions from our students needing
help to schedule their study times so
from YouTube Adnan APUs Kench Walla as
well as teasing are asking one how
should they plan their study schedule
and two if you have any tricks to
organize their time so I you know I
don't know what age group you're in but
one of the tricks is we have released
these schedules that I talked about if
you just go to Khan Academy out or
you'll see several links that say daily
schedules you click on that I'm assuming
y'all are maybe high school age students
but there's their schedules essentially
for every age bucket high school middle
school elementary school
and early learners that's a good
starting point it's there's nothing
rigid about those you can copy and paste
it and modify it to your own needs but
what I would advise is to have some form
of a schedule and make sure your
schedule gives you time to rest and
relax I think you know there's two
extremes that people could fall into
right now and it's completely fine to
not have your act together in this first
or second week but you know there could
be the the the extreme where there's no
structure and and you're kind of just
wandering through your days that doesn't
feel healthy to me after many days or
weeks of that you'll I think feel leaf
and a little bit more blah so to speak
and that's the other extreme we're like
oh I got a study you know 18 hours a day
and all that and that's going that is
also unhealthy so what I recommend is
you can use our schedules or create your
own
but schedules that cover all the
important basics make sure there's time
for gaps don't just try to power through
those gaps I think especially now we
need those gaps even more than ever and
that try to you know get front-load the
work of your day that's actually you
know how I trying to do my life and then
by early afternoon say okay I've done
what I've need to what I need to do to
the day I can give myself a break and I
can you know entertain myself but watch
TV work on a project that I really care
about I can do a little bit of video
conferencing with friends and you know
there's always this question about
FaceTime a screen time and I think
there's good and there's bad screen time
and actually even with sometimes bad
screen time is okay now that we we're
finding more time at home but the good
screen time is that or the better screen
time is especially if you're an older
student is your time learning your time
creating writing coding and I think it's
a valuable time to get on a
videoconference zoom or a google meet or
hangout or Skype FaceTime with friends
and and I encourage you you know don't
just try to go a little bit deeper talk
to your friends about what what you're
really thinking about what are they
stressed about what are they anxious
about and remind your friends that
you're here to support them because I
think we all need to hear that right now
so this is how we sorry
quick question for you it's related to
our OSB product we have a young
YouTube person you so keen a penny who
wants to prepare for the SAT exam and
doesn't know how to start
yeah kita well that we have a very good
answer for for those of you who don't
know college board though the folks who
administer the SAT another nonprofit
they've reached out to us about five or
six years ago and said we want to
address the inequity around test prep we
want to partner with Khan Academy to
make the world's best test prep that
happens to be free and so we launched
that about five years ago and it's being
used by a majority of students who take
the SAT and it's in math reading and
actually writing as well you can write
things to SAT prompts and get feedback
on it and so I think Nina was the name
if I heard correctly but what I
encourage you to do is go to that
official free SAT practice on Khan
Academy you can navigate on Khan Academy
or just do a web search SAT practice
Khan Academy you'll find it and you get
started and try to spend equal amounts
of time in math reading math and reading
especially and also time on writing the
what we've seen in the data is the best
practices for students are make sure you
are working on skills that are pushing
you forward that you're not just trying
to do easy things oh there you go very
good we're getting better at this
technology all the time try to peer you
know follow the recommendations the
recommendations we actually the software
in partnership with the SAT folks it
knows which concepts are most important
for not just for not just for the SAT
but also for college readiness and also
it knows where your weak spots are so as
you answer more and more questions it
will know your strengths and your
weaknesses and so it's trying to give
you the suggestions that are optimal for
you to learn as much as possible if
you've taken the PSAT you can actually
link your PSAT scores with Khan Academy
and if you do that your PSAT data will
inform the software even more what your
strengths and weaknesses are so I would
go there and I know we have you know the
next SCT administration got canceled but
it will come back I am sure at some
point and so I think this is a great
opportunity to spend some time every day
we even have it in some of our schedules
even if you're able to put 30 or 40
minutes a day that
great but and and I would say at least
once a week try to take a full-length
practice test we're seeing that is also
a best practice that helps a lot of
students and when you take that practice
test try to take it in as most realistic
circumstances as you can so yes
spend some time on our official SAT
practice let's see I have a question
from Debbie Charlton says thank you for
all you have been doing to help teachers
to use more during this time as an
ambassador I've been doing conference
calls to help teachers get set up and
move forward the items you created have
been a huge help to many oh well thanks
Debbie for that comment for those of you
know debbie is a one of our teacher
ambassadors we have a thousand teachers
around the world who are super users of
Khan Academy and our super teachers and
they've been incredible mentors for
other teachers and other folks to help
them get started on Khan Academy and
thinking about how they can integrate
Khan Academy into their instructional
practice and especially in a time like
this how they can integrate Khan Academy
into you know their virtualization plan
so to speak so thank you Debbie for
being an ambassador we really appreciate
that you know a lot of what we do is
informed by the teachers on in our
Bachelor community because we're trying
we want to make sure we have as much
support for teachers as possible so Sal
our next question is on from YouTube by
pradya Mishra her question is hello is
it important to make notes each time we
watch a video I think notes can be
valuable I think the most important
thing when you watch a video is to try
to do it in an active way so if the
video is about to go through a worked
example pause the video try to solve it
at least attempt it yourself if the
video is about to explain the stages of
mitosis for example if in your biology
try to think about it yourself say okay
do what do I know about it what do I
don't know about it so you get your
brain primed then on top of that I think
it is useful for a lot of folks to take
notes it helps kind of multiple
modalities to do that you know but for
other people it might be more useful to
just really make sure their focus on
what's being said I think sometimes
notes can kind of be kind of a blind
process too so
the more that you can take notes but
when you take the notes you're really
processing so you're not just writing
verbatim or drawing verbatim you're
looking at what's happening and this is
true whether it's a video or a classroom
you're like okay now let me process that
and digest it in my own words I think
that could be a lot more valuable the
important thing is to really pay
attention and the beauty of videos is
you can pause it and say okay do I
really get that how would I do it etc
and then you can you can play and see
how the the Video Creator has has
approached the concept so on Facebook so
we have RIA Bhatia who's asking will
Khan Academy be putting up AP Computer
Science a courses the AP Computer
Science so we we have AP CS principles
that we already have it's you're
probably aware of it we don't have AP
Computer Science a yet you know what
I've told folks is we're trying to add
subjects as quickly as possible
functionality as quickly as possible but
we are not for profit that is
philanthropically supported and what a
lot of folks my wife was telling me last
night she's like Sal I don't think
people realize the kind of cabinets
philanthropically supported kind of kind
of me as a large team that that you know
and even just our server costs so what I
would say we want to be able to serve
that but we're think we're gonna need a
little bit more resources and I'm not
asking it from urea but I'm asking it
from everyone listening the more support
we have the more bandwidth we will have
literally and figuratively to be able to
create more courses but I hope that over
time we can fill out more and more of
these courses but ap CS principles is
definitely a great place to start if you
haven't done so already and also our
programming platform is a great way to
learn it starts quite simple it could be
used by an elementary school student to
kind of draw and make some animations
but you can do some very sophisticated
things and things like object-oriented
programming and simulations you can go
quite deep on our computer programming
platform as well so Sal we have a
question about AP exams with the changes
and how the exams gonna be administered
on YouTube of to cebra asks should we
study any differently for the AP exam
see now that there are 45 minutes and
online
what you know I I would still let's see
the way I would approach it is and on if
if it's an AP exam that Khan Academy
materials for and we have chemistry
biology physics microeconomics
macroeconomics government and politics
American history CS principles and
obviously calculus and stats if it's one
of those I would still try to get
mastery on Khan Academy you know a week
or two before the AP exam is as far as
you can get and then a week or two
before the exam I would look at old
sample free response questions and try
to do as many of those as possible we
have worked examples of many of those on
Khan Academy and many of those subjects
and so there I would give the same
advice that I gave earlier as when the
problem is presented pause it try to
solve it yourself and then see how I or
someone else might have worked through
that problem but I think if you do that
combination mastery on Khan Academy and
then you have a week or two of really
doing having a lot of experience with
the free response questions and there's
banks of those questions online some of
them have solutions I think you're gonna
be very well prepared for I guess you
know this new modality that we might be
seeing in a couple of about a month and
so I would add to that um Adam on our
content team and I are working on how to
put together a quick how to study for
this based on the new information we
have so that's a resource we're gonna
try to get up hopefully next week to be
students yeah and I don't want to jump
the gun but you know I mentioned earlier
that you know we're exploring ways to do
academic webinars we just did one in
algebra earlier and so as we get closer
to ApS I hope that we we might be able
to explore some things there maybe do
some office hours and things like that
so let's see on Facebook Kristen
Martinez their way to sign course
challenges to students as a teacher and
I'll let the Khan Academy team confirm
what what I'm about to say because I
know some of the stuff is in flux
you can assign obviously specific skills
on Khan Academy as a teacher and parents
can do this too you can essentially may
become your students coach but if they
say add coach and enter your coach ID
and there's resources that explain how
to do that but you can make assignments
of specific skills for specific videos
you can make assignments on unit tests
you can make assignments for course
mastery so you could say hey I would
like you to get 100% mastered in biology
by May 2nd so you can do that and I
believe you can assign course that's
definitely on our roadmap I don't know a
Dan or someone from the team can we
confirm that we can whether we can
assign course challenges while wait for
those those answers once we once we can
get confirmation but I do think course
challenges are a great way and I mean at
minimum you could assign it through
something like an LMS you know you can
put a link to the course challenge but I
I do think they're a great place to
start especially if students already
know some of the material and to
understand where you are in the course
and they're also a great way you know as
the question about AP tests as you get
closer and closer to the AP test I would
take more and more course challenges as
well because that makes sure that you
you you are able to understand what
concept is applicable for a given item
without knowing what skill is from or
what unit and they're all mixed up so I
would take course challenges and I would
do a lot of free response for the AP
students to kind of prepare as it get
closer yeah so Sal just an update on
that one currently you cannot assign
course challenges or spiro the you in
course mastery unfortunately yep you can
assign course mastery you can't assign
spiral view and yeah the spiral view
these distinct some mastery challenges
and those just show up and then the and
then the the the the course challenges
you could just send a link to your
students for it for them get started on
that but yeah unfortunately don't have
that yet where it's you know all of the
other assign
fortunately that comes with it all right
so we have a question from Facebook
Chris sorry um from hot hi reef Mohammed
so how can I be a part of Khan Academy
an educator well I think they you know
we always have job postings outs look at
those but I think you know in the
general sense you know we are always
trying to connect with amazing educators
so you should join our Facebook page our
Facebook group for teachers called teach
with Khan and that you know obviously
stay involved in things like this I'm
I'm exploring other we're exploring
other projects and on how we might be
able to leverage teacher volunteers to
help more students especially this time
of school closures so we will be sure to
keep people posted on all of of the
above alright so I could let's see how
ask another question here someone said I
added an hour to your dailies given for
creative time where my kids have to
create rather than consume their sewing
doodling learning to juggle any other
ideas for kids on what they can create
so I that's a great idea that you added
that creative time you know in our feet
and our first version of the schedules
it was kind of implied that that could
happen in the afternoons or the evening
but that's cool to kind of put it in the
middle I I do think for creative time
depending on what they're doing it is
nice to have large blocks of time so
because you know it just takes sometimes
half an hour just to get set up and then
you might want to three hours to really
create so encouragement people either do
in the afternoon or you can modify the
schedule like that
so beyond sowing doodling learning to
juggle I think there is there's a lot
you know drawing is great there's people
on YouTube who have these drawing
tutorials you can ask them you know you
can you you can storytelling is really
incredible you can ask kids to come up
with a you know alternative reality of
what's going on or or you know what
would the world might look like after
we're through this crisis or
there's just a lot of fun writing
activities we've talked a little bit
about coding in this you know this is a
great opportunity for students to start
exploring engineering things coding
making inventions I think social service
can be creative you know what can
especially kids do for their community
right now I think this is actually a
moment where kids can step up to serve
the elderly especially with maybe
helping them get groceries or just
giving them a source of connection in
this in this time of social distancing
that can happen virtually or maybe just
you know waving to your your neighbor or
you know across the street and things
like that so I think there's a lot of
you know you can make videos you can
make kind of kind of cad amis type
videos explain things to your friends
you can you know actually I played or on
the weekend it was my family in another
family we played this this this game
called Pathfinder it's kind of a new
version of Dungeons & Dragons but that
was it's very creative you go through
these adventures together so I think
there's all sorts of creative things
that you can obviously you know you can
paint you can dance you can choreograph
there's there's a lot that can that can
happen so in closing just one more
question from Facebook Josh Carroll asks
are there ways to perhaps help parents
teach math in ways that show the applied
side say show how to apply quadratic
functions to things like parabolic
motion yeah I mean for that particular
example if kids are curious you could
actually start going into the physics
which we have on Khan Academy and if the
students already know quadratics and
actually if they even know just the
basics of trigonometry which hopefully
they got from some of their geometry
classes but you could even go over that
with them they're ready to go into
things like projectile motion
two-dimensional projectile motion and
and you know one-dimensional projectile
motion you actually don't need any
trigonometry you just need to know a
little bit about quadratics and so
that's a very interesting application
and you can actually see how good your
predictions hold up or you can use the
math to understand you go outside use a
timer throw a ball in the air figure out
how long it's in the air and then based
on that you can figure out how high it
went which is kind of cool you can
figure out how high a ball went by
timing it and then you could say well
how exact is it
because in our equations we didn't have
air resistance now we do and things like
that but I think that's actually a lot
of fun and then obviously you can do the
same thing with two dimensions you could
figure out the angle by maybe where it
lands or how far it went based on
measuring you know there's all sorts of
interesting things you could do with
that so physics R is a great place to
apply that type of thing you'll see a
lot of that in economics as well and a
lot of the basic algebra actually you'll
you'll see in in chemistry as well and
actually some of the genetic stuff in
biology so I think those are all really
interesting they obviously exponential
growth it's not hard to find videos and
we put a few on exponential growth and
how viruses spread and how you can
convert two days doubling to what the
factor is it's being multiplied over any
time period an exponential growth so I
think you know if if there's a silver
lining here everyone should get out of
this crisis learning about
exponentiation and and how to manipulate
it and and what its implications are so
on that maybe not so uplifting note huh
I just want to thank everyone thanks Dan
for helping me out thanks for the entire
team thanks for everyone who's joining
we have some of these quick testimonials
Schatzi cunningham from facebook says my
hope my homes loves Khan Academy we love
you too we are actual home schoolers and
we're subscribed because you break
things down clearly so the youngest
could even understand well appreciate
that Schatzi but you know we love
feedback positive or negative we're
always trying to get better and then you
from YouTube we have Cory Geisler says
thank you for all you do Sal and I want
to be clear it's much more than me Khan
Academy is a team of over 200 people and
we have thousands of volunteers around
the world you have helped me all year
long it's not easy going back to college
at 42 years old so thank you for all you
do well Cory we're about the same age
and yeah I could imagine you know I I
have dreams every now and then I'm going
back to college but I could understand
but I'm a happy we kid we can support
you and I applaud you for going back and
always learning I think that's the
biggest skill it's just continuous
learning so you know thanks everyone
adjoining this is a great way to connect
I feel more connected to you I hope we
all feel more connected to each other
all of humanity is
going through this together and I'm very
confident we're going to get through
this and as we're going through this
hopefully we build some empathy and ways
to connect with each other that we can
carry on once we get to some normalcy
and I will remind everyone we are
not-for-profit we are funded by a
philanthropic donations I want to thank
some corporations that have really
stepped up recently like Bank for
America ATT Google org and Novartis now
to help support our response to the
crisis our server costs are going to be
2/3 x of what they normally will be so
with millions of dollars but we still
need more help we're still running at a
significant deficit and it's not clear
how long we can run like this so we need
help we need donations from everyone
even a two to three dollar donation
these things add up so that we can keep
doing the Duke work we do we can keep
the site performant we can keep serving
folks who might not be in the position
to donate and make sure we can support
the billion of kids around the world who
are out of school and the 50 million
kids in the United States who are out of
school so thank you so much for joining
and I will see you tomorrow
you